Voiceover:Let's say that
we've got the function
y is equal to five times
two to the t power.
Someone were to come up to you
and say, "Hey look, this is
an interesting function."
"But I'm curious, I
like the number 1,111."
"I'm curious at what
point for what t value"
"will my y be equal to 1,111."
I encourage you to pause this video
and think about it on your own.
At what t value will this y be equal
to a roughly equal to 1,111.
If you see the need you might
want to use a calculator.
I'm assuming you've given a go at it.
Let's work through this together,
so we want to say, when
does five times two
to the t power, equal 1,111.
Let's write that down.
When does five times two to the t power
equal 1,111.
Whenever we're doing
anything algebraically
it's always a little bit
useful to see if we can isolate
the variable that we're
trying to solve for,
we're trying to find what
t value will make this
equal that right over there.
A good first step would
maybe try to get this five
out of the left hand side,
so let's divide the left by five.
If we want to keep this being in equality
we have to do the same
thing to both sides.
We get two to the t power
is equal to 1,111 over five.
How do we solve for t here?
What function is essentially the inverse
of the exponential function?
Well it would be the logarithm.
If we say that a to the
b power is equal to c
then that means that log base a of c
is equal to b.
a to the b power is equal to c.
Log base a of c says what power do I need
to raise a to, to get to c?
Well I need to raise a to
the b power, to get to c.
a to the b power is equal to c.
These two are actually
equivalent statements.
Let's take log base two of
both sides of this equation.
On the left hand side
you have log base two
of two to the t power.
On the right hand side,
you have log base two of 1,111 over five.
Why is this useful right over here?
This is what power do
we have to raise two to,
to get two to t power?
Well to get two to the t power,
we have to raise two to the t power.
This thing right over here
just simplifies to t.
That just simplifies to t.
On the right hand side,
we have log base two,
we have all of these
business right over here.
I'll just write it over,
t is equal to log base
two of 1,111 over five.
This is an expression
that gives us our t value
but then the next question is
well how do we figure out what this is?
If you take out your calculator,
you'll quickly notice that
there is no log base two button,
so how do we actually compute it?
Here we just have to apply
a very useful property of exponents.
If we have log base two
of well really anything.
Let me write it this way,
if we have log base a of c,
we can compute this as
log base anything of c
over log base that same anything of a.
This anything has to be the same thing.
Our calculator is useful
because it has a log,
you just press log, it's log base 10.
If you press ln, it's
natural log or log base e.
I like to just use the log base 10,
so this is going to be the same thing
as log base 10 of 1,111 over five
over log base 10 of two.
We can get our calculator out
and we could unlog base e if we wanted
that would be a natural log
but I'll just use the log button.
This is logarithm of 1,111 over five,
so that's this part right over here.
This is log base 10,
implicitly that's what the log button is.
Divided by log base 10 of two
and then that gives us seven,
well it just keeps on going
but is approximately equal to 7.796.
This is approximately equal to 7.796,
so when t is roughly equal to that
you're going to have y equaling 1,111.